Carrie Underwood is summer ready I'm
there I'm ready the country superstar
showed off her killer abs in a tropical
bikini on Instagram writing is it summer
yet the weather was great the singer is
such a vibe rocking a floppy Beach hat
any big smile it was a good day
Carrie has been staying fit in
quarantine I've been like training super
hard she's been hitting the gym posting
pics wearing the cutest workout clothes
and sharing healthy recipes on the gram
in March Carrie told women's health that
she fits in time to sweat whenever she
can something that's not always easy
things to being a busy mom with her two
boys the singer said quote if I can work
out seven days a week
which doesn't happen but if I can I'm
going to because the next week I might
get two days I'd love to sit in a bubble
bath but that's not going to happen
my self-care is my gym time and that's a
stress reliever for me you know I do
whatever I can to make time for it
like I say it goes down for a nap and
I've been in my workout clothes all day
long and I make it happen
Carrie's fitness is not the only thing
happening the 37 year old is celebrating
15 years since her American Idol win
it's just been a complete whirlwind the
singer thanked her fans on Twitter
writing Wow I cannot believe it's been
15 years since my American Idol win it's
been an incredible ride and I couldn't
have made it through without all of you
guys that's how I'm here in the first
place like they've been voting for me
since day one
since I was on American Idol since our
Idol win Carrie has become one of the
show's most successful alums
[Music]
her debut single inside your heaven made
her the only country artist to debut at
number one on the Billboard Hot 100 and
the only solo country artist in the
2000s to have a number one song on the
Hot 100
[Music]
she's gone on to break numerous other
billboard records win 7 Grammy Awards
and became one of the best-selling
female artists of all time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]